with a crisis in ukraine deepening on a
daily basis concerns are growing here in
london and in other european capitals
about the direction of travel of this
incredibly unpredictable war
as you can see the campaign for nuclear
disarmament is out in force other
placards calling for a stop to the war
i come from lithuania i feel like nato
is doing everything they can
i do not necessarily think they should
send their troops to ukraine at least
just yet i hope we can help with
ammunition support money
intelligence
i'm from west of ukraine it's terribly
painful we're crying every day my sister
there
my nephew is in kiev in the
basement bomb shelter sitting with
family
and
it's terribly painful it's unbelievable
but people of ukraine are very strong
you know
do you think do you think that western
powers could go further than they have
done oh definitely definitely in what
way
firstly to stop the gas
purchase the gas and oil from russia
because
this is the most important i think
there is global disdain for russia's war
in ukraine
this is kazakhstan a former soviet state
still heavily under the influence of
russia
and this is the chilean capital santiago
where people are calling for an end to
the violence
in russia there have been courageous
acts of defiance in multiple cities
this is saint petersburg
and this is moscow where police are out
in force
the kremlin's threatened to jail
demonstrators for 15 years and it's
illegal to call the invasion of ukraine
anything but a special operation
on the edge of red square two protesters
sing the ukrainian national anthem
before being dragged away
large numbers of russians opposed to the
war are now fleeing their country
squeezed by western sanctions and
persecuted by the russian state
many of these anti-war demonstrators
were now at the edge of an abyss that we
may not be able to pull ourselves back
from time now say many of these
demonstrators for western leaders to
help broker an almost impossible
political solution to help bring us all
back from the brink
neve barker al jazeera london